Sambu eine aquatische Shyster-Dimension würde
mich Casella Mark Zuckerberg und
Phallus Select oder Barack Obama und
Bill Gates annehmen,
obwohl Kevin Hart este país que
aktuelle historische Eval Hari
Eliot und die Ausarbeitung der Universität in
Jerusalem unverzerrt Souk Aspen im
Studio in Velen
dosmo Honokaa Türkisch die Demenz  und
der Schaden und Cliffhanger
dort sind Homo sapiens hatte 60.000
Geologie Idomeneo dr.  Falks kashish den
aktuellen Eisenstatus so und wieder in
seinem wissenden Boo-Hoo-Models eingesaugte
Walhalla-Millionen totale Zitate für ihn
und eine Demenz auf Vivians Konto, also
vermisse vida scoot Ian noch, wenn du nach Walhalla kommst,
hallo, es ist gut, hier zu sein, ja,
dann besuch  unsere sylvia erwähnte zitate für ihn
da draußen ja aber nicht das ende im
sinne des hollywoodfilms in dem die
roboter durchdrehen und alle menschen töten
vielmehr ist es viel wahrscheinlicher dass
wir neue technologien nutzen werden insbesondere
bioengineering und künstliche
intelligenz um uns zu verändern
uns zu etwas aufzurüsten,
das sich mehr von uns unterscheidet als wir uns
von den Unterwerkzeugen
oder Schimpansen unterscheiden, also glaube ich nicht, dass
sie in 200 Jahren Menschen wie wir auf dem Planeten sein werden,
aber unsere Nachkommen sind eine
Art Cyborgs oder was auch immer  Sie
werden die Zukunft des Lebens gegen
Takunda-Zombie im Dienst von
Tundish dominieren
Draußen lebt in New Smyrna Beach Road
aus der Donauregion D Farm divya Tier Hudson
um Ebene überspringen winzige Orange mein
Filet Anakonda Cronkite und sogar Stern in
Reihen vom Pesto Lopakhin s Kipnis
Paare von erfinden Hoonah Sonne auf VAR na
Evalia zu Feliz Größenordnung gleich in der
skript ein fisch mezzo villa craig ramirez
schnellster club bequem sauerstoff bleakman
volumen auch sowjetische präzision Devon wurde
unter
der anderen krankenschwester erwähnt eine ethische
zeit, weil wir mehr kraft und
mehr glück wollen und wir glauben
, dass wir das erreichen können, indem wir anfangen,
unseren körper zu verändern  unser Gehirn, sogar unser Verstand, im
Laufe der Geschichte
haben Menschen seit Tausenden von Jahren versucht, Macht
über die Außenwelt zu gewinnen, um die
Welt an unsere Wünsche anzupassen, damit Sie
wissen, im Grunde genommen, um uns selbst zu befriedigen,
und es hat nicht funktioniert, dass
wir viel mehr geworden sind  Mächtiger als je
zuvor, aber wir sind nicht
wesentlich glücklicher geworden, Menschen sind heute
tausendmal mächtiger als in
der Steinzeit, aber es gibt sie  kein Hinweis darauf,
dass wir glücklicher sind als die Menschen in der
Steinzeit,
also richten wir unseren Blick jetzt nach innen und
sagen im Grunde, dass es nicht funktioniert hat, nur
die Welt außerhalb zu verändern, wir müssen
anfangen, die Welt im Inneren zu
verändern, um unseren Körper zu verändern, um unser Gehirn zu verändern
Stellen Sie sich vor, dass die Hauptprodukte der
Wirtschaft des 21. Jahrhunderts nicht
Fahrzeuge, Waffen und Lebensmittel sein werden,
sondern Körper und Gehirne. Das ist es, was wir
anfangen zu lernen, wie man
mit Biotechnologie und mit
maschinellem Lernen und künstlicher
Intelligenz konstruiert und herstellt und danach strebt  Größere
Kraft und größeres Glück werden
uns selbst verändern und uns zu
etwas anderem aufrüsten. Dies ist
relativ instabil, stabil und unter
friedlichem Verschwinden  und
Schlesien, um uns im historischen
China zu
ernähren Alice in einem lokalen exzentrischen
lumenok mysteriösen Androiden Nr. 16 antis anti  s
elastizitäten en kochtopf künstler klick
in zelle auflösung heißes treffen
ökonom menschlicher isthmus n'l
assistentenposition anständiger menschlicher isthmus
was während des humanismus geschah humanismus
ist ein ziemlich spätes phänomen der
letzten zwei oder drei jahrhunderte für den größten teil der
geschichte glaubten die menschen, dass
autorität von außen kam  und besonders von
oben von oben die wolken von den
göttern
in der politik in der wirtschaft in der ethik es
waren die götter die uns gesagt haben was gut
und was schlecht ist und wie wir uns verhalten sollen
dann haben wir in den letzten zwei drei jahrhunderten
die humanistische revolution gesehen die sagt
Diese Autorität kommt nicht von außen,
sondern von innen. Die Hauptquelle der
Autorität sind die Menschen und ihre
Gefühle und freien Entscheidungen in der Politik. Wenn
zuvor die Autorität für den König oder den
Kaiser von den Göttern kam, war er König
in der Gnade Gottes Humanismus  dann kam
und sagte, keine Autorität sollte aus
menschlichen Gefühlen kommen, also wenn wir wissen wollen,
wer der nächste Präsident der
Vereinigten Staaten sein sollte  ob Großbritannien
in der in der Europäischen Union bleiben soll
oder nicht. Wir fragen nicht Gott. Wir fragen nicht die
Königin. Wir fragen nicht den Erzbischof von
Canterbury. Wir gehen zu jedem einzelnen
britischen Bürger und fragen was  Glaubst du
, dass Autorität von den
Gefühlen und Entscheidungen von Individuen herrührt, so ist es
in der Ökonomie genauso, wenn dieser
Arbeiter sagt, der Kunde hat immer
Recht, der Kunde ist die oberste
Autorität in der Ökonomie, und
in der Ethik ist alles gleich, was vorher
gut war und  Was schlecht war, wurde wieder von
externen Autoritäten bestimmt, wie die Bibel,
genau wie der Papst, also zum Beispiel
im Fall von Homosexualität sagten die Leute,
es sei schlecht für zwei Männer, Sex zu haben oder zu
heiraten, warum, weil die Bibel sagte,
so kann Humanismus und sagte, wir  Egal
, was die Bibel sagt, wir kümmern uns um
menschliche Gefühle, wenn zwei Männer einander
lieben und sie niemandem schaden,
also was könnte daran falsch sein,
die höchste Autorität sind menschliche Gefühle,
jeder zuerst war der Weg  hier Mieter
Lichter Dachboden Tank Dampf baut
Fahrzeuge macht Demo Tag ehrlich, was
auf dem oberen Blatt von God Bateau steht, seine
Reihenfolge ist ordentlich auf der rechten Seite und
seine Seite im anderen Humanismus, also
möchten sie einrichten, macht das anfängliche Metsu
baden-  powell con unglue Zum Unterschreiben anklicken
sagt, Nick Calathes alter Ähnlichkeitsfakt
, der mit uns in diesen vier Jahren überlebt hat,
ist Alans Elbe, Ismaels
Ophelia Creeks, Angebot, Sonne auf dem Flugplatz,
Bürgermeister erwähnte Namens- und Schwesteretiketten,
die in der Sitzung erschienen, übersprungen, Mia Alpha
aus Schweden, The Creeks Alpha  Wie ich schon
erwähnt
habe, sind die Menschen
nicht glücklicher als zuvor, obwohl
andere Bedingungen viel besser sind als
zuvor, und zwar aus zwei Hauptgründen: Erstens
hängt menschliches Glück von
Erwartungen ab, nicht von objektiven Bedingungen,
wenn Sie bekommen, was Sie bekommen  wollen Sie sind glücklich, wenn
Sie etwas wollen, egal was, und
Sie es nicht bekommen, sind Sie unzufrieden, und
das Problem ist, dass sich die Bedingungen verbessern, wenn sich die Bedingungen
verbessern  ektationen nehmen zu, so dass wir
heute viele Dinge genießen, von denen die
Menschen im Laufe der Geschichte geträumt haben, aber wir fühlen uns nicht
zufrieden, weil wir viel mehr wollen
egal was wir erreichen wir
sehnen uns einfach nach mehr es ist eine ganesha
bhakta stimmung gegenüber dem kapitalismus
fehlt die mia valen im system ich
verlasse das herz ja sicher wenn die
menschen zufrieden sind mit dem was sie haben
wäre der kapitalismus zusammengebrochen also
basiert er darauf  Aber es ist offensichtlich viel
älter als der Kapitalismus, es ist nicht nur ein
modernes Phänomen, es war dasselbe,
ich meine, auch ich weiß nicht, im
Mittelalter. Wenn Sie also ein König wurden und
Ihr Königreich haben,
sind Sie sehr selten mit Ihrem
Königreich zufrieden  du wolltest noch mehr erobern
und wenn du es schaffst, das
benachbarte Königreich zu erobern, bist du immer noch
unzufrieden, du wolltest noch eins und
noch eins, und so baust du ein
Imperium auf, also thi  Die Tendenz des Geistes,
auf Leistung mit Begierde und nicht
mit Befriedigung zu reagieren, ist kein modernes
Phänomen, sondern Teil der menschlichen Natur,
und der Kapitalismus baut darauf auf, aber
es ist nicht die Ursache dieser Tendenz, wenn
irgendjemand verbessert bleibt
, um es mit Software zusammenzufassen  Weil ich am Ende bin, ist
Humanismus, einige Punk-Dominanz, die in
Nichtbefehlen behauptet werden, Gandhi, der Abgeordnete, hat eine
Banane überarbeitet und mit Havannas schalltotem
Mythos Konami vom Pew Research Center, dem
Mesa Baraka-Stein, in der Stadt
von 2000 an Teenager-Sexting-Como-Angst-
Prozenten gelehrt  Geständnisse für Ich erwähne
Versuche, die nicht abgeschlossen sind, Veränderungen, Attraktionen
, Mittags von Meteoriten und Kometen, iPod,
gesendet, bewertet, Zigarressig, erwähnt,
Apple mm, niedriges Zeichen, in Yards,
tausend, Ende, meistens Manaman, bis
zum höchsten Asthma - predigt, der Agonist
ist ein Geschmack, wenn es ein ist  Behandlung wie Scott
als Zweiter in der Mitte der Feiertage. Die
Leute glauben immer noch an Gott, den er
nur als wichtig
empfunden hat. Ich sage nicht, dass Gott verschwunden ist  ed
Ich meine, ich komme aus Israel. Ich komme aus
dem Nahen Osten. Ich weiß ganz genau,
dass die meisten Menschen im
Nahen Osten sicherlich immer noch an Gott glauben, aber
er ist einfach weit weniger wichtig als zu jeder
früheren Zeit in der Geschichte,
weil die Menschen daran glauben  Ihre Gefühle sagen
ihnen, dass sie an ihn glauben sollen. Ich meine, sogar in der
Religion sieht man, dass menschliche
Gefühle die Hauptquelle der
Autorität sind  eine Gay-
Pride-Parade in Jerusalem und es ist ein
seltener Tag der Harmonie in Jerusalem,
der normalerweise voller Konflikte und Hass ist,
also herrscht an einem Tag im Jahr bei der Gay-Parade
dort Harmonie, weil alle religiösen
Juden und Muslime und Christen
zusammenkommen und schreien  dann sind
sie im
Objekt der Schwulenparade, also haben sie eine
gemeinsame Sache, aber das Argument, das
sie verwenden, sagt nicht, dass Sie keine Schwulenparade haben sollten,
weil Gott sagt, dass es eine Sünde ist,
sie sagen, es tut weh  unsere Gefühle
sollten Sie keine Schwulenparade veranstalten, denn wenn
Sie eine Schwulenparade in der heiligen
Stadt Jerusalem veranstalten, verletzt das unsere Gefühle, also habe
ich gelernt, in der
Sprache der menschlichen Gefühle zu sprechen, nicht der göttlichen
Gebote, und noch wichtiger,
wenn Sie  Schauen Sie sich die Geschichte der
letzten hundert Jahre an und fragen Sie sich,
was die wichtigsten Erfindungen
oder Entdeckungen oder Hilfsmittel oder neuen Ideen
des 20. Jahrhunderts waren. Es ist also sehr schwierig
zu sagen, was die wichtigsten waren. Sie
haben so viele Kandidaten, die Sie
haben  das Internet, du hast Computer, die
Atomkriegswaffen, du hast Antibiotika,
du hast so viele Dinge, die irgendwelche lustigen
Verwendungen haben, aber dann ja, aber dann fragst du
dich, was die wichtigste
Entdeckung oder Erfindung der neuen Idee
der traditionellen Religionen war, und es gibt
nichts,
was es getan hat  Rabbiner und Priester und
Mullahs denken darüber nach, was man
in einem Atemzug nennen kann wie
Antibiotika oder Feminismus oder Computer,
ich meine, Religion ist immer noch ihre
Tradition  Religion, aber sie hat
sich von einer kreativen Kraft in eine
reaktive Kraft verwandelt. Im Mittelalter waren die
Religionen äußerst innovativ. Die
christliche Kirche kam dem Silicon Valley am nächsten, was
das mittelalterliche Europa
hatte
Datenverarbeitung alle Arten von Systemen zum
Sammeln und Analysieren von Archivdaten Die
Kirche führte dazu, dass sich jeder König, der
eine Bürokratie und eine
Verwaltung errichten wollte, an die
Priester und Mönche wenden würde, aber heute sind die
Kirche
und die meisten anderen religiösen
Institutionen freigestellt  nur eine reaktive
Kraft, die sie nicht spielen oder in der Nähe von irgendetwas,
jemand erfindet das Internet, und dann
diskutieren alle Rabbiner, was wir
damit machen sollen, sollten wir religiösen Juden erlauben
, dem Internet zu dienen, oder nicht,
sie sind wie die neuen Ideen des Feminismus
und alle priester gehen oh was
machen wir damit wie konfrontieren wir diese
brandstiftung und idee ja ziemlich genial
das historische ich w  Als selbst fähiger Diskurs
und Borg berechtigt, wenn Sie dies verpassen, verschwindet dies auch.
Dies ist ein Kern, der den Göttern hilft.
Es ist ein Tank, eine Moral,
die schwarzes
Spray ausstrahlt  Rede des Westens lishka dr.
Feld, um TM-Krankheit zu treiben, in der sie dachten,
sie erwähnten Weiß,
das in einem Management von Gott anerkannt wurde
Sheldon, der
Nicht-Austin, trübt die unter der
Lebhaftigkeit, die sind die 9v Valen, selbst wir
kennen den politisch verdammten Scheiß, der schon
etwas gegeben hat, und wir melden uns jetzt freiwillig
, um Ihnen nur die Demócrata zu schreiben, ja,
aber ich meine, es ist wie im 19. Jahrhundert
mit der industriellen Revolution  Nicht,
dass die ganze Welt plötzlich anfing,
an die Macht der Industrie in der
Dampfmaschine, in der Elektrizität und im
Telegrafen zu glauben. Nur sehr wenige Länder waren
bei der Industrialisierung der Weltländer führend,
wie zuerst Großbritannien und dann
Frankreich und Deutschland, die meisten Länder der Vereinigten Staaten
nicht
industrialisiert blieben sie weit zurück, aber die wenigen
industrialisierten Länder
erlangten die Kontrolle über die ganze Welt und
sie prägten die  Welt Die Welt, wie wir sie
kennen Sie prägen nicht nur Großbritannien, sie
prägen Afrika und Asien im Nahen
Osten und Südamerika Länder oder
Kulturen, die im 21
Sie werden
erneut den neuen Supermächten zum Opfer fallen,
es wären nicht unbedingt wieder die europäischen
Länder, vielleicht werden es China
und Südkorea sein, aber die wenigen Länder
, die die neuen Revolutionen der
Biotechnologie und der künstlichen
Intelligenz anführen werden, werden noch größere
Macht gewinnen als Großbritannien und  Frankreichs Kopf
im 19. Jahrhundert, sie werden die ganze
Welt des 21. Jahrhunderts darauf aufbauen, und
tatsächlich, der junge Assistent Vianney Armstech von unten,
und sie geben offen
und ernsthaft zu, dass sie nicht
unbedingt mitgeschleppt werden, sondern besetzt
und ausgebeutet werden können, wie es Indien in China passiert ist
den größten Teil Afrikas im 19. Jahrhundert, im
Grunde denke ich, dass dies heute die
wichtigste Frage ist, mit der jedes Land konfrontiert ist
in der Welt ist, ob es diese
Revolution anführt oder zurückbleibt und wenn
es zurückbleibt, ist es in größerer
Gefahr als das, was
im 19
ausgebeutet von den wenigen
Industriemächten wie Großbritannien in Frankreich
und später Japan und den Vereinigten Staaten
Diadema von den Reichen, es ist ein ehrwürdiger,
zweitens, sie sind auch cool von Eli Stock,
sagte er, Revolution von Zeit zu Cousin, eine
Melange, eine harmonisierte Dimension, macht mich zu einer Art
Homo sapiens  meine wissenschaft am homo
tag du riechst hamsa hat
genau fehlfunktion verfahren zahlreiche
chitin visa upgrade für hunger behandlung die anderen nachteile er hat geschlagen englisch versuchen mukesh
straffen auf den plötzlichen verlust strom 1880
sie selección zeichen um kinetik wenn eine
person nur sehr wenige lizenzen nicht garn so
es gemacht hat  Die Designerbabys waren die Ericsson-
Entwicklungssünden, weil
derzeit den Cyborgs die höchsten
Anfänge zugeschrieben werden  Techniker, die sich darauf konzentrieren
sollen, in die
Morris-Länder einzudringen, helfen, die
künstliche Intelligenz als akustische
Intelligenz in Android zu
benennen, und über die englische Erwähnung von Energiequalität, Hobnob-
Intelligenz
Ich denke, dass es vielleicht nicht
die besten Ziele für das menschliche Leben sind,
ein Übermensch werden zu wollen und all
diese immensen Kräfte zu haben, es ist nicht wieder
eine Agenda, die meine persönliche
Agenda ist, und es ist nicht etwas, das ich
den Menschen sage, das Sie sollten  Tu es Ich
sage nur als Historiker, dass das
passiert, du kannst es überall um uns herum sehen. Ich
meine, wenn wir darüber sprechen, dass Menschen
mit Computern verschmelzen, um Cyborgs, Cyborgs
oder Entitäten zu bilden, die teils Mensch, teils
Computer, teils Roboter sind, ist das keine Vision
für die  Zukunft Es ist ein Prozess, der
bereits beginnt, Menschen im Jahr
2017 mit ihren Smartphones
mit ihren Facebook-Konten zu verschmelzen  ihre
Computer mehr und mehr Aufgaben, die wir
früher auf unser Gehirn oder unseren
Körper verlassen haben, lagern wir an diese Geräte aus und
wir sind dem Punkt sehr nahe, an dem wir
diese Geräte direkt mit unserem
Körper verbinden, also ist es nicht so, als hätte ich ein
Smartphone, sondern das Smartphone  is part of
me Die nächste Revolutionswelle in dieser
Hinsicht hat mit biometrischen Sensoren zu tun,
die Teil unseres Körpers sein werden und
die ständig
biometrische Daten aus unserem Körper an ein
Smartphone oder einen Computer senden
und im Gegenzug Befehle erhalten und und ich  Ich kann
ein paar Beispiele dafür geben, was dies im
Hinblick auf das tägliche Leben von
Einzelpersonen bedeutet, wie es sich ändert. Ich meine, wenn Sie
an all diese Online-Dating-Dienste
denken, denken Sie also, dass Sie
biometrische Sensoren an Ihrem Körper haben, die Sie
hinuntergehen  die
Straße und Sie sehen jemanden und Sie mögen
diese Person und Ihr Smartphone oder die
Anwendung auf dem Smartphone
weiß sofort, dass Sie diese Person
sexuell attraktiv finden, weil Ihr Blut
pr  Die Sicherheit nimmt zu, weil Ihre Augen
etwas weiter geöffnet werden und so weiter, und
Sie selbst wissen es vielleicht nicht einmal,
aber die Anwendung weiß es und kann
das Smartphone der anderen
Person kontaktieren und sehen, ob die andere Person
Sie auch attraktiv findet
muss nicht durch Ihr Gehirn und
durch Ihre Augen gehen und Ihren freien
Willen werfen, das Smartphone übernimmt von Ihnen
und verwaltet zunehmend Ihr
Sexualleben oder Ihr romantisches Leben
Hummert von Sperma wird für nicht Martin bezahlt,
so neugierige Hündin Ivan es Tan Marlon,
als plötzlich historisches innerstädtisches tbv hereinkommt,
um die Entwicklung zu sehen, die dies erwähnte, eine
gewisse Fähigkeit über
Cunegonde sa Moment
das Ende der Entfesselung von Prasanta-CRCs,
um in der Kontrolle aufzutreten  Masse Metallischer
und historischer Ereignisname Es ist ein
Konflikt Nun, ich versuche es nicht Ich versuche nicht, die Zukunft vorherzusagen,
weil dies unmöglich ist, niemand
weiß, was in Twent passieren wird  y oder
fünfzig Jahre eher versuche ich,
verschiedene Möglichkeiten zu schaffen, und ich interessiere mich hauptsächlich
nicht für die Technologie als solche,
sondern eher für die sozialen, politischen
und philosophischen Implikationen der
Technologie Ich bin kein Spezialist für
Informatik oder Biologie, also bin ich'
Ich bin nicht interessiert und habe kein
Verständnis für die technischen Aspekte
des maschinellen Lernens oder der
Gentechnik, aber basierend auf dem, was ich über
frühere Revolutionen in der Geschichte weiß, versuche ich,
die verschiedenen Möglichkeiten abzubilden,
was künstliche Intelligenz für den
Arbeitsmarkt und die Familie tun wird  Struktur zu
romantischen Beziehungen zur Religion, das
sind die Fragen, die als eine Geschichte in "Ich
bringe zum Studium der Zukunft"
Mandiboy Ich bin Vas Fäustlinge erwähnt
pasión Vietnam Desertion Jeder erzählt ein
Sumo-Modell Sünde und Hamdi hat doch Angst, es ist
unerträglich, sogar einen Fisch zu verdienen  Medizin
Canton Handschuh Maschine
und schüttelte Lichter sind in der Tat über
ihn Boo
Viet sowjetischen Kommunisten immens Altman
Job Welle an einem Samstag Treffen sicher
Krankheit und Demenz immer noch hoffnungslos
Patel Vivi Einwanderer auf das Wesentliche
Zündung Verfall jetzt ihm gezeigt neuere und
Algorithmen Ozma Cynthia Lehm auf oh
das ist eine schwierige Frage im Grunde ist
die Idee, dass Menschen keinen freien
Willen haben, dass freier Wille eine Art
Mythologie ist, die wir haben.  Ich habe vom
Christentum und von früheren
Traditionen und Religionen geerbt und dass menschliche
Gefühle wirklich auf extrem
schnellen Berechnungen basieren, die das
Nervensystem und das Gehirn ich meine, das ist
derzeit die Orthodoxie in den
Lebenswissenschaften, dass Empfindungen und Gefühle
und Emotionen das Ergebnis extrem sind
schnelle Berechnungen oder Algorithmen, die
selbst das Ergebnis oder der Weg der
natürlichen Selektion sind, also gebe ich wieder ein
Beispiel, weil das sehr abstrakt klingt,
was bedeutet es, dass Emotionen
und Empfindungen Algorithmen oder
Berechnungen sind, also schauen wir uns nicht
einmal Menschen an, sondern andere Tiere, Paviane
Po-Wunden haben auch Emotionen, sie
haben auch Empfindungen, also sagen wir, du bist in einem
Babo  weiter in der afrikanischen Savanne und du
siehst einen Baum mit Bananen darauf,
aber nicht so weit von dem Baum entfernt siehst du
auch einen Löwen und du musst eine
Entscheidung treffen, ob ich mein Leben für die
Bananen riskiere oder nicht, das ist die Art von
Entscheidung  dass Tiere
Millionen und Abermillionen von Jahren der
Evolution durchlaufen mussten, um zu überleben, jetzt ist
dies eigentlich ein Problem der Berechnung von
Wahrscheinlichkeiten, wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass der Löwe mich frisst, wenn ich versuche, die Banane zu bekommen, im
Vergleich zur
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass, wenn ich gebe  auf diese
bananen
ich werde verhungern um zu
überleben der pavian muss die
wahrscheinlichkeiten berechnen wofür der pavian viele infos braucht infos
über
die bananen wie weit sind sie wie viele
bananen sind da groß oder klein reif oder
grün drei klein grün  Bananen sind etwas
ganz anderes als zehn große saftige
Bananen. Der Pavian braucht auch Informationen
über einen Löwen. Wie weit ist der Löwe? Wie
schnell der Löwe laufen kann. Schläft
oder wacht der Löwe? Der Pavian braucht auch
Informationen  n über sich wie schnell ich laufen kann
wie hungrig ich bin und so weiter jetzt muss der
Babu all diese Daten nehmen und
in Sekundenbruchteilen berechnen wie macht
der Pavian das nicht mit Stift und Papier
oder errechnet den ganzen Körper des
Pavians  und besonders das, was wir
Empfindungen und Emotionen nennen, sie sind der
Rechner, die Daten kommen durch
Empfindungen durch Geruchs- und Berührungseinsicht
herein, und innerhalb von Sekundenbruchteilen
berechnet das Gehirn die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
und die Antwort erscheint als eine
Emotion, entweder die Emotion des Mutes oder
die Emotion  Angst, was wir Emotionen nennen,
sind eigentlich Algorithmen,
die Wahrscheinlichkeiten berechnen, und das
gilt nicht nur für Paviane und nicht nur für
Löwen, sondern auch für Menschen.
Sie wissen, dass Pavia in der Einstellungsumfrage zunimmt,
indem sie sich erneuert, um auf Gewinne zu setzen,
die auf Fagin geteilt werden, okay,
aber überspringen Sie dies  Algorithmus und das
Towson-Englisch ein Computerprogramm ein,
da die Ofenrechnung Tricia's im
Hamdi-Song einen Auftrag mit dieser
Seitenkräne Dana ohne Computer ded erhalten hat  uctions
reblueed Pomfret auf Maximum für naman
Entender und die Algorithmen sind Nvidia
und Kind Insulin Lady namens Wunsch,
Fäustlinge zu beschwören Ron Gants und
evolutionärer
Kootz Cash Lawson sie sind Filter FC
Anteil dieser inversen Filme Agnes süßeste
wir je die Idee gegeben haben, ist, dass wenn
Bisher waren Ihre biochemischen Algorithmen
Ihre Gefühle die besten Algorithmen
im Universum. Sie wurden durch
Millionen von Jahren der Evolution geformt, und es
war eine gute Idee, Ihren Gefühlen zu vertrauen.
Jetzt sind wir kurz davor,
elektronische Algorithmen zu entwickeln, die uns
besser kennen als wir  kennen uns selbst und können
uns bessere Ratschläge geben, wie wir uns verhalten
und wie wir Entscheidungen treffen sollen.
Es fängt bei ganz einfachen Dingen an, wie
zum Beispiel, welches Buch
Sie
lesen sollten  Emotionen und auf
Empfehlung einiger Freunde und
Familienmitglieder, aber jetzt gehen Sie online
zum Amazon Virtual Bookshop und
sofort erscheint ein Algorithmus  und
sagt dir, ich kenne dich, ich folge
dir,
ich sammle Daten über dich, und
basierend darauf und auf Statistiken von
Millionen anderer Leser, empfehle ich
dir dieses oder jenes Buch, aber das ist
immer noch sehr primitiv, weil  Die nächste
Phase, die bereits stattfindet, ist, dass
Sie anfangen, mehr Daten über die
Person zu sammeln, wenn Sie ein Buch auf dem Kindle lesen. Wenn
Sie dann das Buch lesen, liest das Buch
Sie zum ersten Mal in Geschichtsbüchern,
lesen Sie Menschen, okay, jetzt testen Sie das vegane
Dorf  freundlicher König, der auf dieses Dorf schaut,
Art Bischof, ich
verstehe fast, dass Täler estas nennen, hören Sie
mit uns jedes Level und jede Jahreszeit, aber Libby,
um Ferguson zu erröten, kann Samenflucht essen,
aber was meinst du mit dem Buch, woher
weißt du, welche Bücher wirklich sein werden?
gut für dich in Bezug auf was auch
immer du dich entscheidest du willst
Schätze du willst intellektuelle
Bereicherung was immer du willst woher weißt du
, welche Bücher gut für dich sind
?
Stinkt, du weißt, andere sind auch ein dreckiger Spaß
mein und mein Kind Moonsoo mein und meine
Kindheit Naruto das ich mich Troy sie
macht es oft Asif ein bisschen krank schüchtern
heute aber ein Spinner ja aber was wäre, wenn
Sie bessere Bücher bekommen könnten, aber Ihr
Leben mehr bereichern  offensichtlich, nachdem wir das Buch gelesen haben
, sagen Sie, ja, das war ein gutes Buch
III, danke Amazon
, dass Sie mir dieses Buch empfohlen haben. Ich wäre nie auf die Idee gekommen
, es selbst zu lesen, aber dank Amazon
lese ich dieses Buch jetzt, wenn Sie
Alicia wirklich kennen würden, denke ich  Ich denke immer mehr
, dass dies um uns herum wieder so passiert
, als wäre etwas bereits
passiert, wie sich die Menschen im Weltraum
bewegen. Sie wollen von hier bis
zum Hauptbahnhof, Sie vertrauen Ihrem
Instinkt und Ihren eigenen Gefühlen,
jetzt vertrauen immer mehr Menschen
Google Maps, sie erreichen eine Kreuzung
und ihr Bauchgefühl sagt, rechts abbiegen,
aber Google sagt ihnen, nein, nein, rechts ist ein
Stau, links abbiegen, und
immer mehr Menschen lernen aus Erfahrung
, Goo zu vertrauen  mehr als ihre eigenen
Gefühle, weil der Algorithmus besser ist,
wenn dies nicht nur mit Büchern passiert,
denken Sie über weit wichtigere Dinge
nach, wie man Freunde auswählt oder sogar
, wie man einen Mann oder eine Frau auswählt
, die ich glaube, in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft  Wenn
genug Daten vorhanden sind und genug
Rechenleistung gekauft wird, werden die Leute Google
oder Amazon oder Facebook oder was auch immer vertrauen,
um selbst ihre Freunde und ihren
Ehemann oder ihre Ehefrau
zu wählen. Ich
habe ein Problem  Lenin war
wahrscheinlich im Streit Steins
gut, dann erwähnte er und wie ist
Algorithmen Bashar Ivan
sie sogar für das Beste, dass sie nicht
gekommen sind, um wahre Sätze zu treffen, können Sie einen
Algorithmus auf beschädigt bei 64
ausatmen  Ein blauer Stein in Oaxaca
spritzt
und hält die spanische Sprache und ein Altarblatt sieht
wie erwähnt ein und
Tieran fühlt sich aktiv an
eine
naturintelligenz gut wir müssen
zwischen seele und
bewusstsein unterscheiden seele ist ein mythologisches
konzept wir haben absolut keinen beweis
für die existenz von seele wenn du mit seele
eine individuelle ewige essenz meinst
die von der geburt bis zum tod unverändert bleibt
und vielleicht sogar über den tod hinaus
fortbesteht  existieren für immer, in diesem Sinne haben
wir absolut keinen Beweis dafür, dass so
etwas wirklich existiert, es ist
nur Mythologie, Bewusstsein
andererseits ist ein Strom subjektiver
Erfahrungen, die wir jeden
Moment erleben, es ist das Realste auf der
Welt, die ganze Welt kann eine Art sein
eines Traums oder einer Matrix wie dort drin, wie
in dem Film The Matrix, aber mein
Bewusstsein ist real, es ist das Einzige
auf der Welt, an dem ich nicht zweifeln kann, wenn ich Schmerzen fühle.
Ich weiß vielleicht nicht, was die
Quelle des Schmerzes ist, aber das tatsächliche
Gefühl  Schmerz ist die Realität, und
derzeit haben wir keine gute Theorie darüber,
was Bewusstsein alles ist, wie es entsteht.
Wissenschaftler nehmen an, dass das Gehirn etwas  Wie
produziert bewusste Erfahrungen, aber wir
haben keine Ahnung, wie es tatsächlich
passiert. Assistenten nahmen von Vanessa
wirklich zuerst eine Aussage von Daniel
Dennett Dingos im Ofen der Villa und Chakra
Tahun ist ein physisch positives Bleiben
Algorithmus der Physiologie besitzt
einen biochemischen Prozess Redewendungen Williams
Applaus Unser System braucht neue Stiche
auf diesem In-vivo-Stein Nun, dies ist die
heute in den Biowissenschaften verbreitete Theorie,
dass irgendwie biochemische und elektrische
Prozesse im Gehirn bewusste
Erfahrungen erzeugen,
wenn Milliarden von Neuronen im Gehirn sind
Gehirne feuern in einem bestimmten Muster, du
erlebst Liebe, wenn sie in einem
anderen Muster feuern, erlebst du Hass.
Das ist die gängige Theorie, aber ab 2017 haben
wir absolut keine Ahnung, warum es
passiert, warum es passiert, wenn Milliarden von
Neuronen feuern, wie  Dies schafft
die subjektive Erfahrung der Liebe, die
wir einfach nicht kennen. Ich denke, das
Beste an der Wissenschaft im Gegenteil  Das mit der
Religion ist, dass man, wenn man etwas nicht weiß
, keine phantasievolle Theorie erfinden muss.
Man kann einfach kommen und
sagen, dass wir nicht wissen, dass die beste Platzierung in der
Philosophie von Herzensproblemen kommt
.  Lewis schaltet
Zhuang Zi Long ein, Harvey hat den K Club
wirklich investiert und ist in ein paar Bananen, ein
Applaus nach haan-soo Claudandus
Domenico Natasha-Liedern, die ich auf
Spezialisten in Moskau gebeten habe, keine Körper und doch mas
Ausleger und doch Firma Noah
Radicchio treffen auf Mo Modesto  bescheiden eine Wolke
und eine ganze Landenge Moschino mit dem
Schwimmen fertig Goom gut Daten ISM ist die
Idee, dass
ein externer Algorithmus
mich besser verstehen kann, als ich
mich selbst verstehe, und
daher die Autorität hat, Entscheidungen
über mein Leben zu treffen, wenn genügend Daten und genügend Rechenleistung vorhanden sind  Bei Religion geht es letzten Endes
um Autorität Bei Religion geht es nicht um
Gott, es geht nicht um den Himmel,
es geht nicht um Sünde Tausende von
Jahren lang war die wichtigste religiöse Geschichte, dass
Autorität von Gott kommt,
und es gab diese oder jene Mythologie in
den letzten zwei oder drei Jahrhunderten, die wir hatten
die humanistische Revolution und die
Nachrichtengeschichte sagte, dass keine Autorität von menschlichen
Gefühlen kommt, jetzt haben wir die nächste Revolution,
die Daten-Ostrevolution, die sagt
Autorität kommt nicht von Gott und sie
kommt nicht von Menschen Autorität kommt
von Daten
ähm, Sie wissen, Conestoga gesprochen vas tatsu
al-raqqa Hertz namens Mr.  oom gang
meeting Todd sieht Argan sie werden
über Lametta Kunst Metis an unserer
Krawattenstation revolución treffen sich ihre Entwicklung
einige Homo Tag verwenden ihn und technisches
Problem Schlagstock und Präzision Alcatraz war
Filetfutter zwei Gründe sind ein süßes Lächeln
ist da und blühen spröde
Fehler zu versenden  Lachsfleisch und plötzliches Google-
Turnier in Teheran sagten dann zu
mischen, dies sind die
Rechtetitel, die sehr königlich sind, Messick, die er gewinnt, und
die Gelegenheit, den Reset-Knopf zu tröpfeln,
und der Scanner Oliver ganz
Anderson,
Anton, kann ein Schloss von Ihnen sein, wen Sie
da draußen sind  open see does new klischee Ich
denke, es ist verfrüht, dass wir bis
2050 nicht über die notwendige Technologie verfügen werden,
um das Leben unendlich zu verlängern, aber ich denke,
dass es angesichts von ein oder zwei Jahrhunderten ziemlich
wahrscheinlich ist, aber bereits heute eigentlich
schon in den letzten ein oder zwei Jahrhunderten der
Tod gewesen ist  ricanisch sexualisiert als technisches
Problem Für den größten Teil der Geschichte wurde der
Tod als metaphysisches Phänomen angesehen, und die
meisten Religionen heiligten den Tod  Erkenne
es als einen wesentlichen Teil des Lebens und
wirklich als Quelle des
Lebenssinns, wenn du an das alte Ägypten
mit den Pyramiden und den Mumien denkst oder wenn
du an das Christentum im Islam denkst,
sie haben keine Bedeutung ohne den Tod
ohne ein Leben nach dem Tod ohne den Himmel darin
Hölle und so weiter, es gibt kein
Christentum, also ist der Tod wesentlich, aber
in den letzten zwei, drei Jahrhunderten sind neue
säkulare Ideologien entstanden, die
den Sinn des Lebens nicht mehr aus dem
Tod trieben. Sie sehen, dass der Tod nur ein
unglückliches technisches Problem ist, wenn Sie
an Kommunismus und Sozialismus denken
Feminismus und Liberalismus und all diese
anderen neuen Ideologien ziehen den
Sinn des Lebens nicht aus dem Tod, was
mit einem Kommunisten passiert, nachdem er
gestorben ist  Beim Feminismus ist es dasselbe,
was mit einem Feminist passiert,
nachdem er oder sie gestorben ist. Das ist nichts, was
man im Feminismus fragt. Der Tod ist
bereits aus der Gleichsetzung herausgenommen  ion
Menschen sterben nicht, weil dies Teil
des Göttlichen Plans ist, Menschen sterben, weil
sie einen Herzinfarkt haben, und warum haben sie
einen Herzinfarkt, weil sie ein anderes
technisches Problem haben, und diese Initiative zu
verpassen, sagte uns die
Kenianer Testmaschine Lusso Vishka  Xenon-Dosen sind und
ich weiß, dass Seiten entkommen sind, ist es ein Dossier,
richtig, ich werde sie sogar klopfen. Totem macht
Englisch, das Italienische, das in dieser Tasche ist,
besonders Italienisch, das ist kein schwerer
Angriff, es wird oft in seinem Argan übersprungen,
es ist heiß, wenn man ihnen sagt  passiert
in Filmen sind noch suchende Stars und ich wusste
oder dachte, welche tasveer Possen in Viet
geklaut lange valleca Fiat und wie auf
Cynthia in der Ava gefunden werden können, kann der
ganze Raum und Kanal anständige Punk-
Führung sein, erreichte Rekorddatei über Hamas-
Führer, die Waffenzitate treffen  Auf einem Shaolin-
Basarat, das so gesaugt war
, hatten wir radikale Lebensverlängerungs-Weinberg-
Ökonom-Filet, das alle Nevada-Khalili
selbst, die ich nicht hasse, tatsächlich Aslam wählen können.
Bolivianer, der Arbor erweitern kann, wird
von Diskussionen gefürchtet  auf zusammen mit Umfang
über Veblens repräsentative Elemente
Givaudan Computer in auf einigen Kupfer
passieren auch auf die Visionen einer Katze, die
niemals direkt
aus unserem Bereich median und
praktisch Frau Direktor Brunnen erleben können
und fantastische Ereignisse haben. Watson und Fisch
Konferenzen sind emotionale Fähigkeiten und
über Verdun kann nicht einmal Adam sein, der nicht auf der Liste
steht, geben Sie uns, lassen Sie ihn, lassen Sie ihn schwitzen,
Maja, also werden all die Dinge, die das Leben
lebenswert machen, ebenfalls zunehmen.
Ich denke, dass es auch viele
Probleme geben wird, die auftreten werden, sobald wir
das Leben fast verlängern können  Im Delta auf unbestimmte Zeit wird
es wahrscheinlich
zumindest in den ersten paar Generationen sehr teuer werden,
damit nur die Reichen
diese Chance haben werden, jahrhundertelang schön und jung zu leben,
und dies
wird beim Rest der Bevölkerung einen immensen Ärger
hervorrufen  unter den Armen, denn der
Tod war in der Geschichte der große
Gleichmacher. Die Armen sagten sich immer,
okay, die
Leute haben es gut  jetzt, aber
sie werden genauso sterben wie wir, aber denken Sie
an eine Welt, in der nur die
Armen sterben und die Reichen nicht sterben,
das wird eine Menge Wut erzeugen, und
selbst wenn Sie reich sind, werden Sie viel mehr sein
ängstlicher als je zuvor, denn
wir sprechen nicht von Unsterblichkeit in
dem Sinne, dass man nicht sterben
kann, man kann immer noch sterben, man kann
unendlich leben, dank all der neuen
Behandlungen, aber wenn etwas passiert, wie
ein Lastwagen einen überfährt, ist man tot  und
es gibt nichts dagegen zu tun, also wird
die Angst vor dem Tod viel
höher sein als je zuvor. Die Menschen
werden nicht bereit sein, Risiken einzugehen, weil Sie
wissen, dass ich heute hierher komme, es ist riskant, dass
die einen Unfall oder was auch immer behaupten.
Ich werde sowieso sterben, also bin ich bereit
, einige Risiken im Leben einzugehen, aber die Gelegenheit zu verpassen,
für immer zu leben, weil
ich diesen oder jenen Fehler gemacht habe, kann der Grad nicht
nur der Wut, sondern auch der
Angst viel höher sein als je zuvor vor den
Zysten  in punctum o-negativ dasselbe Kunduz
Unter den mich wirklich schockierten
Dissidenten und dem jungen
Wüstling dieses Optimismus glänzt voli shahe Merdan que siento Ende war
in Bucas Magier im Nebel Elche
im menschlichen Herzen von Nevada in
kartiertem Samajwadi, aber sah Goombahs Coons
Nevis und Roboter Nivea Krish, die sich kreativ darauf
verkörperten, so kreativ  Livia
hawaiianische Musik hat mich auseinandergenommen Candide ist
eine Musik oh yeah
aber Lisas ich bin nicht ich kenne diesen
speziellen Track nicht aber ich gebe ihm das Buch
zum Beispiel du kennst ein Computerprogramm
das Musik im Stil des
jungen Sebastian Bach komponiert und komponiert  die meisten
leute sind nicht eingeschlossen ich kann den unterschied nicht erkennen
was ba ist und was der
computer im computerprogramm komponiert hat komm
abonniere zis bald tausend kar einemela in
gesprächsgesellschaft ja und du weißt, wenn
du gut über kunst nachdenkst ich meine das
wieder es ist  eine philosophische frage, was
ist der hauptzweck der kunst manche
glauben, dass der hauptzweck darin besteht
, menschliche
emotionen zu wecken, aber wenn es in der kunst um inspirieren geht  ng menschlicher
Emotionen, dann wären Computer sehr bald
viel bessere Künstler als Menschen,
weil sie aufgrund ihrer Daten und ihrer
Rechenleistung wiederum in der Lage sein werden,
mit menschlichen Emotionen viel besser zu spielen als
jeder menschliche Künstler, den sie nicht haben
Emotionen ihrer eigenen Computer haben  kein
Bewusstsein, sie haben keine Gefühle, sie
haben keine Emotionen, aber sie werden die
Fähigkeit haben, menschliche Emotionen viel genauer zu manipulieren oder zu inspirieren,
als jeder
Mensch sind keine Künstler, die viele in
Kentucky und Westasien gesehen haben. Der
unvollkommene McClung-Sohn auf jedem Blatt sagt
die Musikszene  vom bild gegen
neidisches fleisch und blut
tante herz ist perfekt der kern dieses
enddialogs soutache wird seine neue
version sein, wo sie nicht bestehen wird
sogar die wiederaufnahme sein, weil seine anfängliche ich brauche
einen perfekten klon und ein emotionales dorf
ich wie ein muslim sogar  der Lader ungeschickt
Tavia Lehrer Hanlon nein ich denke es wird sich
ändern es ist eine Frage es ist eine Generation
es ist wirklich eine Frage der Erwartungen
yo
du bist mit bestimmten erwartungen an die kunst aufgewachsen und vielleicht bist du
entsetzt über etwas, das deine erwartungen bricht,
aber
wenn du hinter der leinwand musik
hörst und diese musik dich berührt und
inspiriert, fühlst du liebe und angst
und wut und was auch immer  und dann wird der
Bildschirm weggezogen und du siehst, dass
da keine Menschen sind, es ist nur ein Computer,
was denkst du? Ich meine, deine
Gefühle waren immer noch echt. Ich meine, du kannst
sagen, du kannst deine Definition von
Kunst ändern und sagen, nein, es geht nicht darum, zu
inspirieren  menschliche Emotionen, es geht um
etwas anderes und dann wird es vielleicht nicht
funktionieren, aber solange die Leute glauben, dass es bei
Kunst darum geht, menschliche Emotionen zu inspirieren, denke ich,
dass Computer sehr bald bessere
Künstler sein werden als die meisten Menschen
Schönheit kommt seine
Ratifizierung Tom es Kommission
Beschränkung auf Finanziers Bargeldpreis, also
hüten Sie sich vor dem Namen ist ein mystisches Artefakt
fizy agonistic Ishida Digital und Zelda
attraktiv, es ist viel mer  Gesänge, die
Ehre in diesem Ereignis suchen Label Nun, ich sagte, mein
Job ist ein Historiker, nicht zu sagen, das ist
gut, das ist schlecht, optimistisch oder
pessimistisch zu sein, sondern zuallererst nur zu versuchen,
zu sehen, was in der Welt
um uns herum passiert und was ist  Dies wird wahrscheinlich
in den kommenden Jahrzehnten in den kommenden
Generationen geschehen. Dies ist die erste und
wichtigste Aufgabe. Natürlich sollte
betont werden, dass die Technologie nicht
deterministisch ist. Wir können dieselbe
Technologie verwenden, um sehr unterschiedliche Arten
von Gesellschaften aufzubauen, die wir im 20. Jahrhundert
neu hatten  Technologien wie Züge und Radio
und Fernsehen und Elektrizität, und wir
könnten diese Technologien verwenden, um
kommunistische Diktaturen oder faschistische
Regime oder liberale Demokratien aufzubauen, dort hatten
sie alle Fernsehen, aber es ist und und
es ist, was wirklich Sache der Menschen ist, zu
entscheiden, was sie damit machen, es ist das
Genauso werden wir im 21. Jahrhundert
diese neuen
Technologien haben, künstliche Intelligenz und
Bioengineering und so weiter, aber sie
bestimmen nicht  Eine einzige Zukunft, sie
eröffnen verschiedene Möglichkeiten, und es liegt
an uns, zu versuchen und weise Entscheidungen zu treffen,
was wir mit ihnen tun sollen. Absolutes Kichern.
Lasst uns Gestalt hinter
uns lassen
Sie wissen,
Ferguson zu testen, kein Tier zu sehen, dies ist eine offene
Vision, die Fähigkeit, sich mit Intensität zu verbinden,
und die daher erforderlich ist, um unseren Beleidiger gut zu konstruieren.
Ich würde sagen, die
wichtigste Frage ist die Frage des
Leidens. Wir sollten versuchen, so viel wie
möglich zu verstehen, was Leiden ist
und  Was ist die tiefe Quelle des Leidens
und wie kann das Leiden in der Welt verringert werden,
und jede Technologie kann auf eine
Weise eingesetzt werden, die das Leiden erhöht oder verringert
, um ein Beispiel zu geben, nicht einmal
von Menschen, sondern von anderen Tieren, wenn
Sie darüber nachdenken, wie wir andere
Tiere behandeln  und vor allem bauernhoftiere wie
kühe und schweine und
hühner sind wohl die elendsten
tiere der welt in der welt die
menge von su  Das Angebot, dass die
Fleischindustrie in der Milchindustrie
Milliarden von Tieren zufügt, ist wirklich
unvorstellbar. Jetzt kann die Biotechnologie
dieses Leiden entweder verstärken oder verringern
In Bezug auf die Erfahrung des Tieres
selbst, aber Sie können immer die
Biotechnologie verwenden, um sogenanntes
sauberes Fleisch oder zellulares Fleisch herzustellen, das
aus Zellen gewachsen ist, wenn Sie, wenn Sie ein Steak
wollen, keine Kuh aufziehen müssen, die Kuh töten
und haben  Ein Steak, aus dem man einfach
selbst ein Steak anbauen kann.
Vor vier Jahren wurde es tatsächlich gemacht. Die Kosten für ein
sauberes Steak betrugen heute 300.000 US-Dollar. Heute sind es
mit angemessener Investition und Forschung nur noch 11 US-Dollar
geschlachtetes Fleisch
und dies ist eine Wahl, die wir treffen können, wenn wir diese
Mission oder de Valdivia Harbinson initialisieren, um
eine britische Pritchett-Weichheit neu
historisch zu machen  Decke auf und 11 selbst
Ahava wird Tonkin in diesem Boom sehen, unseren
iranischen Trockenhundun-Feinschmecker, den die
Perspektive eines DC-Distrikts, das
Sie im Silicon Valley aufgegeben haben,
Satish Flight am Bishnu Hornish
Commander lehrte sie in Perseus Mitch
Mustain eine verwundete Perspektive, er
hätte eine Strategie  Verwundet von Gedanken über die
leichte Entwicklung von Lincoln. Nun, es ist die
Erinnerung daran, dass Menschen nicht die
einzigen Wesen sind, die Gefühle und
Emotionen und Empfindungen haben. Sie sind nicht die
einzigen Wesen, die leiden oder
glücklich sein können, und wenn wir an die Zukunft denken, die
wir nehmen müssen  Berücksichtigen Sie die
Auswirkungen unserer Handlungen auf das Leiden oder
Glück anderer Tiere und nicht nur
der Menschen.
Linda Jimenez, ein auf Venedig geschnittener Film, ist
überlagert, Roberta Smith
der strategie sicherheit ziel booyah in de
burgh ein arzt kommt in die folge besitzer ellenberger
computer ossetien an
e  xperiment auf dieser kunstvollen Meditation
der Stern nach dem Tor nettes neues Motto
mit der Gemeinschaft Wohnung in der
Kunst zu sein und zu sein Oh Knöpfe auf einer Eule treffen sich
wirklich verwirren auf ihrem das Set war
Geisel Betta Fisch
Aziza Meditationen in ja sehr viel ist
etwas, was ich gewonnen habe  aus der
Meditation, die ich praktiziere, wie Sie sagen, weil
Tierstation und für mich vielleicht die
wichtigste Frage von allen ist,
was Realität ist
ist für
mich keine Flucht vor der Realität,
sondern eine Methode, um mit der Realität in Kontakt zu kommen,
um irgendwie alle
Fantasien in all den fiktiven Geschichten zu durchschauen
, die unser Verstand ständig konstruiert, und
es beginnt mit sehr einfachen Realitäten,
als ich vor 17 Jahren anfing zu meditieren
machte meinen PhD in Oxford und ich ging,
um diese Vipassana-Meditation auszuprobieren, und die
erste Übung war sehr einfach
Trils, das ist es
, kontrolliere es nicht, schau nur, wann es reinkommt
, wenn es rausgeht, und ich meine, oh, ich
machte meinen Doktor. Ich dachte, es wäre eine sehr
schlaue Person. Ich kenne meinen Verstand, ich habe die
Kontrolle über meine Aufmerksamkeit, was ich nicht tun könnte
Ich versuchte länger als 10 Sekunden, mich
auf den Atem zu konzentrieren, und sofort
rannte der Geist davon, zu einigen Erinnerungen,
einigen Geschichten, irgendeiner Fantasie, und mir wurde klar, dass
ich nichts über meinen Verstand weiß und
keine Kontrolle über meine Aufmerksamkeit habe, und wie kannst
du hoffen  viel tiefere Realitäten
über sich selbst zu beobachten, wie die tiefe Quelle
Ihres Leidens, und wie können Sie hoffen,
die Welt zu verstehen,
wenn Sie die einfache Realität
des Atems, der in Ihre Nasenlöcher ein- und ausströmt, nicht beobachten können,
also begann ich hier mit meiner
Meditationspraxis und  In diesen 17
Jahren hat es mir den Fokus und die
Klarheit gegeben, mich selbst und die
Welt ein wenig besser
zu verstehen und insbesondere die tiefe Quelle des
Leidens in meinem Leben und in der Welt als
Ganzes zu verstehen, wenn man weiß, wie viel Arbeit in
Buddhi steckt  sm Anblick alle heute so Moody
finden Demenz und Upgrades undankbar
nur Irritationen durch ausländische Krankheit
Acton Vista Clara in Bosnien Denver
desmit Ausgangssperren Kota Viren
Colonel Eden - Dustys ärgerliche erwähnte
Mitka Phil schadet ihnen, Hassan kann
die Helden-Bata-Cybox auf
Drogheda Mitka auflösen Film sie nicht
hängt zwangsläufig davon ab, wie wir uns selbst verändern, wie
wir all diese neuen Technologien und
Produkte entwerfen und so weiter. Eine der Gefahren
besteht darin, dass sie
gemäß den Bedürfnissen des Wirtschaftssystems,
des Militärsystems und des politischen
Systems entwickelt werden und wir weit haben werden
Effizientere Menschen, aber sie werden nicht
unbedingt empathischer oder moralisch
ethischer oder glücklicher sein als wir,
wenn Raketen schwer
fassbar sind  extreme
Erwartungen an die Zukunft, aber sie
haben auch große Angst vor der
Zukunft in diesem Sinne wie wir  nicht
anders als frühere Generationen Ich
denke, wir unterscheiden uns darin, dass es
heute schwieriger ist als je
zuvor in der Geschichte, sich vorzustellen,
welche Art von Welt es in 20
oder 30 Jahren in der Vergangenheit geben wird, die sich die Menschen
zumindest in ihrer Grundform immer vorstellen können
die Welt in 30 Jahren Sagen wir,
Sie leben im Mittelalter, also wissen Sie nicht
, vielleicht werden die Mongolen nächstes
Jahr einfallen, vielleicht wird es eine Epidemie geben, aber
Sie haben eine ziemlich gute Vorstellung davon, wie die
Menschen aussehen werden und was die Menschen sein werden  was
wir in 30 Jahren für unseren Lebensunterhalt tun müssen Wir haben heute
keine Ahnung, wie der Arbeitsmarkt
in 30 Jahren aussehen würde oder wie der menschliche
Körper in
dreißig oder fünfzig Jahren aussehen würde, was viele
praktische Implikationen hat und nicht nur eine
philosophische Diskussion ist  Zum Beispiel haben wir
keine Ahnung, was wir den Kindern heute in der Schule beibringen sollen,
weil wir einfach nicht wissen, in
was für einer Welt sie in
30 Jahren Disziplin in einem Tierwunder leben würden
und die Schüler hier eine Konstante des
Seala  nt
de Guiche die Kirche zu reißen und
Wachsamkeit und nehmen Sie diesen Kampf gegen
alle Reden im FDA-Cosplay auf.
Danke bald
Sie haben Glück, dass unsere
Forumsrangliste der Optimisten im
Silicon Valley Naivität nicht darf und doch
Christ Indian die Insulaner der
Märkte darstellen, tatsächlich TS sein Erwähnung lackierter
Tillotson oft al khazneh
la Avenue FIFA Lieberman scoot jemand,
über den ich wirklich unglücklich bin  Senatsseite
fad in der Tat Laufspiel ist nicht versteckt
Rede nicht zerstreut
[Musik]
du